it's called becoming an icon and it's
hosted by Emmy Award winner Liliana
Vazquez and celebrity makeup artist
Joseph Carrillo here here's a part of an
upcoming episode celebrating cardi B
check it out
so growing up people gave her a nickname
Bacardi like you know that's what my
friends call me when I was five on the
playground like tequila tequila Lily
Bacardi cardi B wow her mind was the
future I think it goes to prove that
cardi has always had a really good eye
and ear when it comes to branding
herself it's definitely one of the many
reasons why she cemented herself as an
icon
Liliana Vazquez AKA tequila Lily and
Joseph Carrillo joins us right now good
morning good morning that's a secret my
mom's watching well you told everybody
on the podcast you forget on podcasts
that the whole world could listen
because it's such an intimate space you
don't know what you're revealing and
you're like did I say that and that's
the great thing about this podcast you
have been interviewing celebrities for a
long time why did you want to tell the
stories of latinx artists well I think
it's exactly that right I'd been working
as an entertainment journalist for
almost just a decade and what I saw was
that there's a disparity in how we cover
latinx artists in mainstream media so to
be able to give them this platform and
the opportunity to tell our stories
Joseph is Mexican I'm Mexican and Puerto
Rican in this way was really meaningful
and I think really powerful for us as
Latinos and for our audience to hear and
be inspired by these incredible Journeys
but part of the fun to me guys when I
listened is the dynamic between the two
of you you've known each other for a
long time it starts it sounds like this
podcast came there had been a little
drinking a little Googling and then this
podcast was born but how did you two get
together so I actually tweeted her I saw
her on TV and she was talking about
being Latina so I tweeted her and she
immediately wrote me back and I was like
I'd love to do your makeup we clicked I
actually think there were Margaritas
involved when we first that was a theme
but we hit it off because we both kind
of started From humble beginnings and we
were both first generation we're both
Texans he's from El Paso I'm from Fort
Worth and we both love fashion we love
music we love this inner entertainment
industry and and we love these people
what's so interesting to me I knew bad
Bunny's music but I didn't know his
backstory I didn't know guys six years
ago he was bagging groceries ago and now
he is This Global Superstar I mean
massive I mean you're talking about 18
plus billion streams his the most
streamed artist on Spotify three years
in a row he just headlined at Coachella
the impact that he's making globally
right now is obviously what makes him an
icon but it's what makes him like this
Global Superstar on a massive scale yeah
in Spanish so he's an icon is there a
common definition that you've come to uh
what makes an eye oh that's a good
question
artist yeah so we're basically the way
we look at this is like we're looking
for Global impact
um what they're doing in the world we're
looking for brand recognition like JLo
yeah like if you walked into any bar or
any club in Asia in South America and
you heard a JLo song everybody knows the
lyrics everybody has a memory and that's
what's so special about the podcast for
us is we're reliving all of these
memories that we had growing up to this
music through that and that's what
people do with music it connects us
right it's Nostalgia and it's so fun to
relive like our childhood growing up in
Texas in the 90s to Ricky Martin right
to Claudia Stefan all of these this
music that defined who we are a lot of
our identity is tied up into this music
and these experiences your format is
interesting too because when I'm
listening I go okay when's the JLo
interview coming when's the Bad Bunny
and it really is just the two of you
that clearly is a deliberate choice just
the two of you talking yeah why did you
think Joseph that's the best way to do
it it's very entertaining and not boring
at all thank you I mean listen I can't
even take credit for that we have an
amazing team but I feel like when you
get to hear the people talking this was
about us and our experience and taking
people back like the people that are
listening to this they want to hear the
memories too because it takes them back
to where they are yeah it's nice that
it's not a straight interview podcast
this is very much like a narrative
documentary style podcast we are
chronicling their Journeys all the way
from the start like some things you
might not even remember or know about
these artists and so this podcast isn't
just for people that are fans of JLo or
bad money we want people that aren't
fans to come and listen to that because
by listening to the show you're going to
become a fan of this person what are
some facts that you guys might have
uncovered could you say your
investigative entertainment journalists
yes
give us a good Bad Bunny fact okay so I
think with Bad Bunny
um you know we talk about what an impact
he's made in dismantling like machismo
stereotypes in latinx culture he was
dressing up in women's clothes when he
was shopping with his mom back in Puerto
Rico when he was a teenager people were
like oh he just started doing this for
attention fashion has no gender exactly
he said that that's what I learned on
your podcast when he was a teen he said
that so and that's his authenticity
coming through and I think with JLo one
of the things that I thought was
incredible is that like she started as a
classically trained ballet dancer here
in the Bronx that's right you know I
didn't know that about it he's on In
Living Color yeah it took off from there
she was the Fly Girl statue Liliana
Vazquez
thank you so much new episodes of
becoming an icon drops every Wednesday
wherever you get your podcast